all right we we have so much to cover
today that i'm not even going to waste
time
talking about the world famous benefits
of membership i'm going to skip that and
jump right into material because there's
just too much to cover and this is
really interesting
economically we have
all over the map opinions about a recent
statement by joe biden
about so-called free riders on the
unemployment
insurance enhanced unemployment
insurance that is currently available
now for framing for context any social
insurance program
has the possibility of free riders
people on
food stamps who shouldn't really get
them but they're using
business expenses to artificially lower
their income so that they qualify for
food stamps or whatever or
people who choose not to work or not
work as much
in order to qualify for medicaid instead
of working
and earning more and paying for their
health insurance for example
now no honest person who understands any
social insurance program will tell you
that free riders don't exist they do
exist
but the point is when we think about
macro economics
uh instead of the micro of such programs
if the programs are finely tuned if the
benefits are well calibrated
if the means testing is appropriate and
enforced
assuming it's a means-tested program you
basically don't worry about a few
anecdotal
free riders because they are relatively
few and
the program overall at the societal
level at the macroeconomic level
is a positive thing for the economy
that's the general approach to any
properly administered
social insurance program right now
we do have a unique circumstances with
so-called
enhanced unemployment benefits through
the federal government during the
pandemic now normally unemployment
insurance and benefits are a state thing
states determine
the level of benefits they vary by state
they tend to be higher in states with
higher wages and higher cost of living
and that's
fine and that's how it all works in this
case and this is a very rare situation
because of the pandemic
the federal government came in and they
dropped an enhancement
on people in many cases disconnected
from what they were earning
in the job they lost due to the pandemic
so you can always say there are
some people choosing unemployment
insurance instead of working
we don't worry about it because
unemployment insurance
runs out the benefits aren't huge
there's not that many people who even
could earn more
from the unemployment insurance than
from working
uh it's also um uh
just a truth about humans that
people generally want to feel useful and
they want to work so while
sure anecdotally there might be some
people
in normal circumstances that have
figured out a way to earn the same or
almost the same from staying home it's
not really a macroeconomic concern
in this particular moment because of the
enhanced
federal unemployment there are more
people
who theoretically could earn a little
more
from staying home and collecting the
normal state unemployment benefits
plus the enhanced federal benefits then
from going back to the job
that they had that that is theoretically
possible right now and anecdotally it's
happening
so joe biden gave a series of remarks
yesterday on the economy
and talked about how jobs numbers from
april were short of what was expected
and one reason that's being cited is
that because of this enhanced
unemployment
there are more people than usual turning
down jobs
so that they can stay home and collect
that sweet sweet enhanced unemployment
so joe biden says he's going to deal
with that let's take a listen
well look fifth thing we're going to do
we're going to make it clear that anyone
collecting unemployment
who is offered a suitable job must
take the job or lose their unemployment
benefits
there are a few coven 19 related
exceptions
so the people aren't forced to choose
between their basic safety
and a paycheck but otherwise that's the
law
now there are already a ton of things to
talk about here
first of all as joe biden says this is
already the law
all of these unemployment systems in
each state sometimes it's by phone
sometimes it's online there's different
ways that it's done
you regularly have to answer questions
like are you looking for a job
did you apply for jobs have you been
interviewed were you
offered a job that you turned down so
joe biden is not
creating any new law here joe biden is
saying
we're going to enforce the rules on
unemployment
interesting it's really difficult to
enforce
people are self-reporting there's
relatively little confirmation or
oversight there's no central database
where the government could determine
you said you weren't offered any jobs
but you were offered one and you
declined it it's basically the honor
system
uh so this is really just kind of like a
message from joe biden
i don't really know how much will be
done as a result of it but let's listen
to a little bit more
i know there's been a lot of discussion
since friday since friday's report
that people are being paid to stay home
rather than go to work
well we don't see much evidence of that
that
is a major factor
we don't see that that look it's easy to
say
the the line has been because of the
generous unemployment benefits
that it's a major factor in labor
shortages
americans want to work americans want to
work
as my dad used to say a job's about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity your place in
the community
being able to look your kid in the eye
and say everything's going to be okay
i think the people who claim americans
won't work even if they find a good and
fair
opportunity underestimate the american
people
so we'll insist that the law is followed
with respect to benefits
but we're not going to turn our backs on
our fellow americans
22 million people lost their jobs in
this pandemic
through no fault of their own they lost
their jobs to a virus
and to a government that bungled its
response to the crisis
and fail to protect them we still have
eight million fewer jobs than we did
when the pandemic started
okay so you get the idea so there have
been two reactions to this
one reaction has been great get these
free loaders off of unemployment
you have restaurants you have other
businesses that can't find workers
so the story goes because people are
happier staying home
and making enhanced unemployment rather
than going back into work
the reality is this is statistically
rare it's
possible because of enhanced
unemployment there are anecdotes about
it
but i worry that by even doing this
joe biden is buying into this right wing
narrative that we have no particular
reason to accept
we don't have to accept that right wing
narrative but there's another side to
this
which many people are reacting with if
the wages are
so low at these jobs that you do make
more
staying home on unemployment isn't that
a sign that maybe the wages are too low
raise the wages in order to attract
employees
now remember this is not normally as
much of an issue
when there is not the enhanced
unemployment this is really a transient
issue enhanced unemployment from the
federal government is going to be ending
in all likelihood later this year but
what does it say about the wages being
paid
another practical difficulty is biden
says
you know you can't turn down a suitable
job and continue to collect unemployment
who determines if it's suitable if you
lost a job making
65 000 and you're offered one making 13
an hour is that suitable do you lose
unemployment benefits if you don't
accept
that job so i think that this is
basically unenforceable
i'm curious to see what enforcement
there will be i think enhanced
unemployment is going to end before
there's any real enforcement
and much of the problem is that i see
joe biden by doing this as playing into
a republican criticism which is barely
valid
again any social insurance program
anecdotally you can find instances of
anything the question is
at a macro level is that actually a drag
on the program
enhanced unemployment has been a huge
saving grace for so many people and my
concern is biden's just buying into it
too much and it's not really the problem
that republicans claim it to be
let me know what you think if you ever
feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
ten different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video